well that's the rebound commas and blows
up around the court welcome guys
this 26th of the year Mary is handling
out front Lopez went off the three-point
line steps to the side and fires gringo
by 8
[Music]
Lopez again that's what John Nancy got
the gym and said you know what
I want to get on the floor it up now you
9 + 64 Middleton finds the shooter again
musiques exact example were talking
about he's in Ralph's he might be
outperforming that new contract already
our all good
12 games in Lopez
[Music]
cut inside wide open look for local
business and Lopez knocks it in from the
corner nuggets buy one
[Music]
that was a good challenge by Jochen she
got out there and as a hand up and Lopez
scores anyway the game have been made by
front core players either four or five
[Music]
yokas tries to challenge
the point attempts he's made for
Lopez and Lopez knocks it in so it's a
battle the big man from distance
he used to excel built of trying to get
a wave of Gary Harris these guys shoot
the basketball
no there's there's Lopez never moved
from that spot don't build gonna take
that hits again let's go get the long
rebound breaks it up
[Applause]
believable what Lopez breathing on his
hand trying to cool off the fingertips
now you got a guy making seven threes
and licorice anything that nuts Steph
Curry range he feels it and he not even
hesitate they've got the offensive
rebound play time on his shot clock
he feels it and he not even hesitate
they've got the offensive rebound play
time on the shot clock shot to get out
all set
[Applause]